gentlemen we're live
ladies and gentlemen welcome to a
special edition of the pbd podcast
emergency press conference emergency
podcast to discuss
the recent russian invasion of ukraine i
know a lot of you out there have been
asking for pat's feedback on this he's
actually traveling on a business meeting
right now he's in
mexico but we did not want to delay our
commentary and our feedback on this so
with that being said we brought in pbd
live from mexico to give his thoughts on
what is happening in ukraine pbd are you
with us
i am can you hear me yes i can sir
i'm in my hotel room right now my wife
is like babe all the kids are waiting
for you downstairs we just had a
business meeting all morning
came from lunch and i'm getting stories
pat how come you're not talking about
this how can we not have like i've been
traveling but uh look a few things i i
just finished watching a press
conference with president biden which by
the way i have to say i was very
impressed with the way he handled the
questions at the end we'll cover that as
well as what the actions he's taking
there was a question asked about him
whether he's going to get china whether
he's reached out china to help out
to get russia to slow down it was very
interesting what his answer was which
we'll talk about that as well
and then how we got here you know a bit
of the history what does putin really
want a few questions that i've been you
know a lot of people are asking me and
i've been thinking about it myself but
before anything else here's the one
thing to keep in mind
um there's a lot of videos that are
circulating when i hear that alarm the
that alarm it's like like this i go back
to iran being six years old and saddam
and khomeini were going at war and it
was a mess when this was taking place
uh and
you know there's a lot of history on how
that goes back to that area but first
things first the press conference uh
president biden put out some major major
sanctions on all russian banks every one
of them uh trillion that over a trillion
dollars of assets every russian
businesses that are linked to u.s
anything from russia that's doing
business in u.s all the accounts have
frozen here the market in russia tanked
45 just yesterday that's nearly a
quarter of a billion dollars the market
loss in a day uh gas prices are going up
because a lot of the world we're not
pumping our own gas right now we're not
fracking as much as we could we're
relying on other places this is why
you're seeing gas prices going up even
though president biden is saying he
doesn't want the gas companies and oil
companies to exploit this opportunity
it's not about that gas prices are going
to go up these
people that are running small gas
stations it's a small business owner
it's not like they're billionaires
millionaires they're just trying to make
eight cents on a dollar they're making
you know whatever the numbers is but the
markets felt it uh in russia videos are
being shown
with people that are protesting outside
and russian police is coming immediately
arresting these guys and some of the
places they can't even get in because
there's so many people out there saying
stop this whole mess we don't need to be
doing this
it's not looking pretty but putin's
planned this for quite some time
i've been saying gas prices are about to
go to ten dollars in california for a
while it's gonna get there it's already
at six dollars we have a bunch of people
here with us
that are from california talking about
how they're feeling immediate gas prices
as of yesterday on top of that for quite
like a while weeks maybe a couple months
russia's been
right around the border and everybody's
saying what are you doing nato just had
a meeting at geneva saying hey why are
you over here or nothing it's just
regular training you can do it you're
pretty big you can do training
everywhere anywhere why are you doing
your training right on the border and
you're building hospitals and you're
moving a hundred thousand troops all of
us 125 000 troops 150 000 troops and now
over 175 000 troops blood they got
everything prepared that in case
something were to happen you know
move blood supplies hospitals
everybody's ready for that i think
russian air force one of the units the
airborne unit took over a small airport
that's right by kiev because they have a
whole strategy on what they want to do
with the capital
they know they don't have a lot of time
it's not like this is going to be a
six-month war or a three-month war they
have a small
window that putin's trying to capitalize
and we're going to see whether this is
going to be taking place or not over 40
people have already been killed one
ukrainian platon was shot down with five
people that were killed this just
happened
and uh you know for some people that are
wondering like who is ukraine you know
what is the big deal with ukraine why is
ukraine so important is it that
important of a country i'm in u.s i'm in
texas i thought texas was big i thought
new york was big why is everybody you
know going crazy over ukraine what
supplies does ukraine have so there's a
couple different arguments here one of
the arguments is
the fact that you know uh this is
putin's ex because putin wrote about
this how when soviet union fell in 1991
and when it collapsed
at that time you know ukraine became its
own country russia became its own
country
and you know this is during cold war and
uh ukraine became independent and at
that time when ukraine became
independent people have to realize
ukraine inherited most of soviet union's
nuclear power this is what a lot of
people don't know they inherited most of
the nuclear power let me give you some
stats so you know how much this was 176
inter-count intercontinental ballistic
missiles
1249 numeral warheads 44 strategic
bombers 700 nuclear-tipped cruise
missiles 2 000 tactical weapons all of
this went to ukraine and ukraine at the
time
the the leader that they had wasn't
somebody that you know he was a he was a
pretty strong personality himself
and uh russia comes in and negotiates in
1994
they gave all those weapons up to russia
so think about this majority of those
weapons were given up to russia in
exchange for negotiation
russia promised them guaranteed security
we're never going to mess with you we're
going to respect ukraine's sovereignty
all this stuff is going on right now
while this is taking place
a few things happen we they signed the
budapest agreement let's kind of try to
make this work let's be peaceful let's
not make anything happen the original
signers i think was us uk
i want to say belarus and you know
kazakhstan so they signed it let's make
this work right afterwards in around
2013
the leader of
ukraine was victor yanukovych okay who
was a puppet to uh putin and he was more
pro-russia than pro-ukraine which kind
of helped out he was a corrupt guy
heavy-handed pro-moscow and during that
time while this has taken place
2013 he the leader rejected an eu deal
so the eu comes in and says hey let's
make this work let's kind of come
together come join nato come join eu
we're going to give you an offer he
rejected the deal but took 15 billion
dollar bailout from russia putin okay so
this is a guy that was you know
for russia even though he's running
ukraine anyways eventually he's replaced
by the current pm the current president
he leaves he goes to russia some people
didn't want him to leave some people
wanted him to leave so that's one part
of the argument that to putin was like
ukraine's been part of soviet union for
the longest time there's no way i'm
gonna give up my ex there's no way i'm
gonna let my ex go marry somebody else
and if he my ex she marries nato or she
marries eu there's no way i'm gonna let
that happen so putin's made some demands
to uh uh nato and here's his demands you
ready crazy demands by the way number
one his demand was
for nato to stop expanding that's the
number one demand number two i believe
they're up to 30 countries right now
eastern europe which is just not gonna
happen withdraw from all troops from
eastern europe and number three for
america to vow
not to protect their allies with nuclear
weapons for america to vow not to
protect their eastern european allies
with weapons right
where they are so all of this stuff he's
asking so he wants them to come back he
wants to move quickly in kiev he wants
to replace with a new leader but this is
the one part most people also don't
realize
what ukraine has let me give you some of
the rankings of what ukraine has in
regards to size there's 604 thousand
square kilo kilometer kilometers so it's
pretty good size i think it's 44 million
in population and i want to say their
gross domestic produce i think their gdp
is around a quarter of a billion dollars
where 156 billion dollars is their gdp
that's where they are 156 good size
population 44 million relatively good
size but there's more to it than that
here's a few stats ukraine ranks first
in europe in proven recoverable reserves
of uranium ores number one in all of
europe second place in europe and 10th
place in the world in terms of titanium
ore reserves okay second place in the
world in terms of explored reserves of
manganese ores 2.3 billion tons or
12 of the world's reserves
second largest iron ore reserves in the
world that's 30 billion tons okay second
place in europe in terms of mercury or
reserves third place in europe third
13th place in the world in shale gas
reserves fourth in the world by the
total value of natural resources seventh
place in the world in coal reserves
that's 33.9
billion tons so people have i can go on
and on and on about other things but
agricultural power you know food needs
of what they can do they can meet the
food needs of 600 million people this is
a very important country in an
industrial industrialized country this
is not some small country we're talking
about that none of us know about because
we're going about our business you're
trying to be a realtor someone's doing a
you're a nurse you're a doctor you're
not thinking about the stats but putin
knows who ukraine is and they want to
back so it's a battle right now on the
west side of ukraine a bigger part of it
they're more pro-ukraine on the eastern
side of ukraine they speak russian
they're more tied to russia they follow
more what putin has to say the left side
is more the eastern western side is
following a little bit more of what
european has to say they want to be part
of eu they want to be part of nato so
that's some of the stuff that's going on
there it's important for us to know
those things couple other fast facts
that we need to know one in six
ukrainian
is ethnic russian okay one in six one in
three speaks russian
as a native language so now
all this is upset and done
even though what putin says
in a way does make sense you're a part
of us
this has been a part of us
we did a deal we want you to come back
this belongs to russia
and let's just say you have a few kids
with your ex-wife
but your ex-wife has kind of moved on
she has kids it's been a long time it's
not like it's fresh off a divorce
this is not a fresh divorce this is a
31-year divorce that took place and in
31 years emotions change
relationships change a lot of that stuff
changes now
let's go to another place that we're
going with this whole thing and what
their outcome is so they want to
capitalize everything that's going on
over there etc etc okay
will this work is this strategy of what
putin's trying to do work well
biden today when they were doing a press
conference just 30 minutes ago 40
minutes ago
he was saying the sanctions all this
other stuff they're asking the questions
afterwards and he asked questions from
everybody
there was a moment he was about to be
quick
and a little bit uh sarcastic with the
fox news guy that he called the son of a
[ __ ] or stupid son of a [ __ ] dude but
he was very respectful you can tell they
had a call together yeah is it peter
ducey yeah
peter ducey yeah so
one of the people asked a question
saying so have you put any sanctions on
putin yet he says not yet we haven't
gone to those measures okay
so these sanctions
are do you think it's gonna work i do
think it's going to work
why do you think it's going to work
because when the economy is affected and
people feel the pain
they're going to eventually get to them
and say hey we cannot go with the way
that we're going right now we have to
make some changes okay
he says do you think that a person asked
do you think this could lead to
the next cold war he says i don't think
so why not because two-thirds of the
world agrees with us great point by the
way so for some of the people that like
nato is a part of us that we're on the
same page eu is part of not wanting to
see this happen their neighbors they
definitely don't want to see this happen
and then they ask the question about
india are you on the same page with
india have you guys had the call he says
we haven't had the call with india yet
we're going to have it later on today so
i don't know why india because you know
india has never been not good with china
and if you're not good with china china
is good with russia so it's kind of
interesting why we're not talking to
india because they're they're pretty
important ally for you to have a
conversation maybe they just haven't had
it yet they'll have it this afternoon
but there was one question i was asked
and the question was
you know um
have you uh
uh uh are you urging china to help
isolate russia
this was exactly the question i'm giving
you the quote of the question are you
urging china to help isolate russia this
was biden's answer
i'm not prepared to comment on that at
this moment
what do you mean by that
because what does china and russia have
in common
they both have an x that they want back
one of the x's for russia is ukraine
and x4 china is who
they want them back
so is there a wink-wink deal behind
closed doors between jia and putin
saying you take that i'll back back you
up but when i take taiwan you better
back me up is that what's gonna happen
because as this whole thing's been going
on and we saw china picked up hong kong
just recently so it's not like 50 years
ago just a couple years ago when that
happened
we saw taliban pick back up afghanistan
okay because a lot of people are seeing
what's going on so what does this lead
to here's what one of the
speculations you're hearing from
different people
and what they're saying the speculation
you're hearing that hey why is trump
supporting uh what do you call it putin
i don't know if you saw what trump said
about putin uh in a quote saying hey did
you see the quote what he said about
putin he says i applaud him about the
decision he's taking advantage of the
opportunity right now what do you mean
by that
what do you mean by that to make a
comment like that are you saying
he's doing the right thing or is it
i respect them for capitalizing off this
opportunity so is there an opportunity
well let's weigh this part out what is
the opportunity okay so many a few
months ago we were doing a podcast and
on that podcast we talked about the fact
that you know
uh
a a girl dates a guy and this guy
uh always made her feel safe okay but he
was a very serious guy but he made her
feel safe
and made her feel secure anyways she
eventually leaves him for a pretty boy
nice guy because she says i just don't
want to deal with a guy like this i want
to date somebody that's a little bit
more you know easy going chill
attractive so she goes and dates this
pretty boy anyways they go to a bar in
the bar a fight breaks out
and the pretty boy backs up and she's
not he's not protecting her
and the ex is there and the girlfriend
goes back to her ex because the ex is
making her feel safer than the current
boyfriend pretty boy well why are you
going back to your ex so a lot of people
are saying
if trump was president today would this
have happened well we definitely don't
know that but some people on the right
are saying
everybody thought trump was going to
start world war three well did he
when trump was president did anything
happen with
isis we never once heard about isis
did anything happen with
you know north korea because one time
north korea i saw that tweet today where
north korea said i have my finger on the
button
okay it's always next to me and then
trump retweets and responds back to
you know north korea
what's his name kim jong-un and says he
says i also have the button right next
to me all the time except my button is
bigger and my button actually works
right you remember when trump said that
to north korea and people are like well
you can't say something like that
because you kind of poke in the bearing
what if he does that
but the other guy on the other side like
[ __ ] he kind of does have access to the
same thing and if i do anything he's
gonna destroy my entire country and have
nothing and if trump was president today
this becomes another question and we can
kind of open it up and talk about this
if trump was president today
would putin have done this i don't know
if trump was president today would the
taliban have taken over afghanistan many
will say no and many on the left like
matt zeller who was a former cia who
cannot stand trump cannot stand tulsi
gabbard he called that tulsi gabba did
you see what he said on the tweet he he
sent me the tweet this is what he called
tulsa yeah but tulsi gabbard tweeted out
this yesterday
17 hours ago she says this war and
suffering could have easily been avoided
if biden administration nato had simply
acknowledged russia's legitimate
security concerns regarding ukraine's
becoming a member of nato which would
mean u.s nato forces right on russia's
border and he responds
you're a traitor and a coward resign
your commission and go home to your
handlers in moscow right so zeller is
not a fan of tulsi ziller's not a fan of
trump but he's still not happy about the
way biden handled
the afghanistan issue with taliban so
what did it have been differently if
trump was here is are they kind of
looking at this opportunity and saying
hey you know uh this is a good time for
both of us to go in let's capitalize
i'll get taiwan you get ukraine it's a
perfect perfect time to do it under
biden he won't do anything about it so
for those that said that
well
biden kind of put some strong sanctions
on putin and russia like it's not like
he didn't do anything about it he put
the sanctions now is that gonna be
enough i don't know
a lot of people were saying oh it's just
a bluff
putin's just a bluff he always says this
it's a bluff this wasn't a bluff folks
right this is real people died there's
videos of bombings all over the place
which many of us have probably seen at
this point if we play the clips it's
probably a replace of what you've
already seen yourself
tyler i don't know if you have access to
one of them if you can play one of them
when the jet drops those two bombs
and you see the kids screaming
and you see the woman with the blood on
her face i don't know if you have it
ready or not if you do play it if you
don't we can continue yeah so i think
this is it here i'm going to share my
screen really quick and we'll get it
all right pbd we're gonna play this
video now
press play and hit the audio because the
audio is down right now turn on the
audio first turn on okay there you go
[Music]
i didn't hear the audio i don't know if
you guys are the audio or not because
okay good did you guys hear the audio
okay so if you want to pause that and
and i mean that kid's screaming my kids
screamed last night at four o'clock when
she woke me up because she wanted to
have their diapers changed and she
wanted to eat that's a different scream
than this scream that's painful as a
parent hearing what many of these
families are going through people are
blown away that this thing like
i don't mean it like they're they're
surprised on what's going on nobody
expected it to escalate to this point
right now okay
so these are some of the things that's
going on i mean i'll pause tyler adam if
you guys have any commentary any other
thoughts that's kind of what's been
happening the last couple days here no
well said and you covered a lot of the
topics that we'll get into a little bit
more in depth uh obviously we talked
about the nuclear weapons with ukraine
gas prices we want to see what your
thoughts are or where you think gas
prices will end up where do you think
the stock market uh will go from here
how much it'll be affected we'll talk
about the sanctions we'll talk about
um obviously the relationship with china
what i want to get your opinion on pat
is really putin's mindset here so i'm
going to read you a couple quotes and
then you can kind of
come in on the other side here obviously
his major concern is the expansion of
nato nato currently i believe it has 30
countries originally
formed in 1949
to protect ironically against soviet
aggression that's currently what's going
on and with the collective security
clause basically they agreed to
consider an attack against one of the
countries that against attack against
all so a couple quotes for you so
obviously putin does not want the
expansion of nato he does not want
ukraine or georgia for that matter
joining nato and he's obviously backing
the russian
separatists in ukraine that's what he's
doing but here's a quote putin has
basically called ukraine
little russia he says its language never
existed it does not exist now and it
shall not exist in the future modern
ukraine was entirely and fully created
by russia more specifically the
bolshevik communist russia so
with that history
what do you think
putin really wants out of ukraine we
talked about obviously the history
history and one-sixth of russians having
one-sixth of ukraine's having russian
descent one-third speaking ukrainian we
talked about the natural resources but
in your opinion where do you think
putin's mindset is at
look at he's not wrong on what he's
saying it is little russia because if
you look at the map
tyler if you want to just pull up the
map for people to see it ukraine is this
big compared to russia so he's not lying
in regards to territory right
uh but in regards to resources no he's
not he's not telling the truth
ukraine is a very very important and by
the way
during the cold war the the main arch
rival of us was ukraine like that was
the the country people looked at people
looked at ukraine and who they were and
you cannot forget that gorbachev's
mother is from ukraine like gorbachev
grew up knowing the song the national
anthem of ukraine so you're not like
you know i understand what he's saying
and this is an emotional thing for him
uh as he's talking about this but yeah
if you look at the map right there and
make it a little bit smaller go go to
the map for people to see how small
ukraine is because that actually makes
ukraine look big go to a different map
you look at how small ukraine is
compared to russia it's astronomically
uh different but right now the challenge
is
the the the leader of ukraine today he's
not backing down
the the the ambassador went up and
calling out russia saying how could you
do this
war crimes are not allowed this is a war
crime he's not lying this is a form of a
war crime because it's not like putin's
doing it in a way of let's sit down and
negotiate he's kind of doing it like a
dictator i mean that's just the approach
he's taken he's not taking the let's
collaborate and talk exactly look at
that that's russia that's ukraine so he
is right on how small ukraine is
you froze for a sec you with us he has
he doesn't even they ask the bite have
you had a conversation with putin i have
not are you planning on speaking to him
i am not are you not planning on
speaking to him or are you
just not getting put in to say he wants
to speak to you which one is it we don't
know is putin really even
considering your voice and the demands
you're making i don't know i don't know
if he's really sitting there
listening to the demands he's making in
regards to how this affects everybody
this event is going to affect everybody
the economy is going to be affected by
fyi one thing to be thinking about which
is pretty interesting
uh uh
is
while the moment the attack started this
morning the moment the attack started
this morning fyi the moment the attack
started this morning so it's very
important to know ethereum skyrocketed
today
it went up
okay when the war started ethereum went
up okay
it was down to 2300 it went up to 27.50
okay why
are people feeling a little more safer
and crypto with their money today i
don't know
is that where a lot of the money moved
bitcoin moved in the last eight hours 12
hours from 34 000 to nearly 40 000. what
caused it right that's a complete
different conversation that adam you can
investigate to talk about on your show
that's blown up right on valuetainment
money sauce cast you may want to
disclose that and see what it is maybe
investigate that a little bit more are
people feeling a little bit more
comfortable going into the crypto side i
don't know all i can say is uh the
economy is going to be affected just so
you know the military industrial complex
that they talk about they're gonna make
so much money right now the the
president of uh uh of uh ukraine said
we're giving away free guns
hey if you're willing to stay and you're
not escaping because all the gas
stations are lined up people in ukraine
are so afraid they're leaving
where the president of ukraine said
we're willing to give you a free weapon
if you stick around if you stay for
chrome we're going to give you a weapon
but the question everybody's asking is
where do i get the weapon from i'll
stick around but where do i get it so
there's a lot of you know
not miscommunication lack of proper
communication for people that want to
stay and fight for their country but
they can't get it and they've already
taken over a small airport
who knows what's going to be happening
here but there's going to be major
effects around the world with this the
question is this is going to work or not
well you bring up a really good point
with a theorem with bitcoin and if you
looked at this stock market and
obviously the stock market is not the
economy and economy is not the stock
market but it's a good indicator
this morning everything was in the red
obviously since the attacks on uh
ukraine from russia everything was red
it's a little after four o'clock right
now pat i'm going to get your thoughts
on this
dao up 92 s p up 63 nasdaq up russell
2000 up bitcoin up big ethereum up big
amazon tesla disney nvidia apple
facebook google everything's up
including
um
treasury bonds
you would assume
when a potential world war three is
about to happen
a a
a groundbreaking groundbreaking war
across the world
that when the when everything went into
the red this morning it would continue
for the day if we're not days after
based on your business acumen why would
the stock market and every major index
go up from here what are your thoughts
i will tell you this biden looked very
strong today
biden looked very strong today okay you
have to know what we talked about on
this show is we're going to talk about
what we see we're not sitting here
defending one side or another biden
looks strong today and
that gives the american people a lot of
confidence you know a lot of times a
political strategist will say anytime
you're losing and you're you're what is
it uh your uh polls are down what's the
what's the award your um
uh uh uh when the
support president
what not your base you're losing your
base
no no not at your base when the support
the president's getting that poll
everybody looks at the favor
yeah say that again your popularity your
favorability your popularity but
popularity uh
uh percentage is down your vote is down
people are not like they're not feeling
good about this guy right now what's
that
approval rating is what i'm approval
rating is down
um
there's a few ways to get it back okay
one of them is a war because it is a
strong position that you have okay but
this is not a war that biden started
okay this is not a war that america
started right this is an opportunity
that this man's been capitalizing off of
and i can guarantee you putin's been
meaning to do this for a long time if
you ever read putin's blog the article
that he wrote it's like a love affair he
asked for ukraine and he was heartbroken
when he was first coming up and there
was that division of the families and
everybody going their way so he's been
wanting to do this for a long time and
he saw this as the perfect opportunity
to do so but here's the thing
let's talk about the following let's
talk about consequences
okay
because the average person is watching
this you made a great point
bitcoin is up you know ethereum is up
i'm talking crypto then you talk about
the stock market everything is up
treasury's up america looks strong today
america looked pretty good today america
looked like they stood up to the bully
today that's a good thing for him to
stand up and stand up to the bully today
and by the way you can watch the whole
press conference with the briefing with
the president today go watch the
questions at the end the whole thing is
like 25 minutes but watch the last seven
minutes eight minutes that's the main
part if you don't have 25 minutes to
watch the whole thing i recommend
everybody to go watch the seven minutes
on going back and forth there's a couple
parts that you may want to catch
is the following question consequences
number one um
so
what do sanctions do
because everything's got a side effect
if i eat a lot of cheesecake there's a
side effect
if i drink too much red bull there's a
side effect
if i gamble my money there's a side
effect
if i fight with my spouse and i you know
belittle them all the time there's a
side effect there's side effects to
everything right okay
what is the side effect
to
putting sanction on russia the way that
you didn't you cost 45
okay
um
when we put sanctions on china
it looked good for a month
they look good for two months
they look good for six months
it looked good for 12 months
128 months of constant consecutive
expanse of monsa
and then puff out of nowhere this thing
showed up called kobe now not telling
you it's bio warfare conversation
but you push the bear cove it popped out
and it kind of ruined the whole world
for about 18 months threw everybody off
it was a mess and we're barely coming
off of this thing here right now with
masks kids going to school all this
stuff barely and we're not even there
yet with many of the states right
we live in florida we know florida we're
not even in fact you don't even feel it
but the rest of the country illinois
michigan new york jersey california
so
what is russia specialty
is it nuclear war because they got a lot
of nuclear weapons i think they're
number two behind us
would he pull that one off
i don't know has that been russia's
specialty
or is russia gonna play the proxy game
and what is the proxy game
is it gonna be a different strength that
they have
one of the strengths russia has is cyber
warfare
russia is very good at cyber listen many
of us know the effects of a bio warfare
if it was a bio warfare which we don't
know if it was a biowarfare the
investigation hasn't yet been done but i
think the tribunal world needs to
investigate and find out what happened i
don't know you don't know nobody knows
the government doesn't know we haven't
done the proper investigation yet we
don't would like to find out what
happened there we haven't gone and done
the proper audits etcetera etcetera
but do we know what happens if we go
through cyber warfare
has anybody ever had their
password taken from them
you ever had your instagram profile
where you get an email saying you're
about to get verified you fill out that
information you put your password boom
somebody takes your account over and
asks you for five thousand dollars or a
bit going to get your instagram back has
that ever happened to you you ever
gotten a call from american express
talking about the fact that hey let me
tell you somebody's doing fraudulent
activities we put a freeze and you get
that call from one eight hundred two two
four and you know it's amax you ever had
those kind of calls you ever had a call
like that and what does it do to your
day you ever had your you know social
security you ever had somebody take your
stuff and go get a bunch of credit cards
and spend a bunch of money you ever had
that happen before how much of a pain in
the ass is it never had to go recover
and go get a second social or change
your social because things got pretty
bad
we don't know the effects of a cyber
warfare folks we don't know it
and putin's not a guy
that
they would
move on
hey you know i believe in god and god
asked me to forgive and i gotta move on
putin doesn't come across as the guy
that's gonna go and say heavenly father
shall i forgive president biden for
putting all the sanctions on my people
and publicly humiliating me and he got
in the way of me getting ukraine back
which is part of our motherland and
that's one of our family members but he
got in the way and i'm determined and
convinced that was supposed to happen
and i ask you for forgiveness in advance
for what i may do to u.s and america
none of us know
so we don't know what's going to happen
with the consequences we don't
the best thing that we know is the
following
here's the best thing that we know
is that nato is unified
eu for the most part is unified
and america
is not too happy
about what he's doing but the only
people that are not we've heard nothing
from china
nothing why
i don't know
so if those two guys are on the same
team and the rest of the world says well
who cares what they want to do let them
be on the same team
they're not too lightweights you know
how in sports like allowing shaq and
kobe to get on the same team yeah it's
gonna be three championships you can't
let
a powerhouse like russia and a
powerhouse like china to team up you
ain't just letting the two of the most
powerful players in the league get on
the same team let's just say chicago has
michael but lakers have kobe and shaq
that's kind of what's going on today so
there are some things that i hope our uh
government our president our military
leaders are having these types of
conversations behind closed doors and
i'm sure they are
i'm sure they're way ahead of the game
we have a very strong middle
and
for the most part
i love this street i want to
are not willing to selling their souls
souls out to another country like that
but we have to pay very close attention
and not be naive about the fact that
putin's not going to sit there and allow
somebody to publicly humiliate him i'm
convinced that's not his character pbd
speaking of biden in the press
conference that he did and our allies
really you know nato uh the eu g7 let me
read you a couple quotes and let you
weigh in on this so president biden said
that um putin has chosen a premeditated
war that will bring catastrophic loss of
life and human suffering putin chose
this war he unveiled some new
devastating sanctions on russia meant to
punish the country for its full-scale
invasion in ukraine
before he did so he conferred with the
g7 countries before the sanctions were
imposed biden said quote unquote putin
is the aggressor putin chose this war
and now he and his country will bear the
consequences sanctions will be imposed
at severe cost on the russian economy
both immediately and over time sanctions
include four russian banks and corrupt
quote unquote corrupt billionaires and
their families who are close to the
kremlin aka putin's inner circle in a
joint statement from the leaders of the
g7
they've said putin has reintroduced war
to the european continent he has put
himself on the wrong side of history
furthermore the eu commission president
ursula van der leyen promised to quote
unquote weaken russia's economic base
and its capacity to modernize following
the barbaric attack by russia against
ukraine following that she said
we will free russian assets in the eu
and stop the access of russian banks to
european financial markets so you
brought up the concept of consequences
and biden looking strong and what we're
doing with all our allies so what are
your thoughts on some of the quotes that
biden nato the eu
has basically laid out there well and
really quick to piggyback off of adam um
you know
back to tulsi gabbard's tweet that that
if we had just listened to his concerns
with nato do you think that carries any
water regardless of biden or trump or
who would let this happen had we
listened to
putin's concerns with nato would he
would he have stepped down and said all
right i'm not going to invade just stay
out of nato i don't want uh american
allies on my border you know in in 2014
it used to be the g8 summit it was
russia was a part of the giant summit
and we kicked him out when he invaded
crimea let's not forget that obama said
listen just have vladimir give me some
space when i win re-election he can do
what he wants he can he can invade crime
crimea are we taking the wrong stance
with this are we isolating and
alienating vladimir putin if if we were
to let him back in and and talk with the
big boys would he stop being so
aggressive and take a step back i mean
how much how is this is this really
about reuniting ukraine to get back to
the ussr or is this vladimir putin
protecting his interests his country and
and keeping ukraine out of nato
do you remember what matt zeller's uh uh
uh
uh colleague said who was uh uh from the
taliban and what he told them what we
have he said you guys have all the money
we have all the time you remember that
you guys have all done you guys remember
that quote you have all the watches we
have all the time
you have all the watches we have all the
time which means we don't give a [ __ ]
about your money we're patient we're
eventually going to get what we want
which is afghanistan and they got what
they wanted how much weapons did they
get what's the number 80 billion we've
heard 40 to 80 billion dollars of
weapons they got from us that's what
they got okay
so let's take that position tyler on
what you're saying with the
president obama being caught on
recording saying what he said i'll let
you though let me just get reelected and
it's surprising that that didn't hurt
his re-election uh uh you know uh uh and
and he got what he wanted still but
let's say let's say that's the case and
let's just say we get closer to him
would he allow this to
not happen and would he allow not to
have a fight to go after ukraine do you
really think
putin is going to set aside his
ambitions
for a friendly dinner
do you really think putin is going to
set aside
his strategic tactical ambitions
of a true believer
for you inviting me to nato
do you think in life a priority to him
and a goal in his life is to be part of
the g8 g8 or to have ukraine be part of
russia again
what do you think
i mean that's the real question
you have to sit there and ask yourself
what certain enemies and opponents you
face
what is more valuable to them when
you're doing a negotiation with a
hostage crisis negotiation let's just
say let's just go to
somebody who took your child
and they have your kid hostage
and you call them and you say what is
the negotiator asking
what are you looking for and the guy
says the typical negotiation is what i
want six million dollars by this point
to transfer to this account and i'll
release the kid right okay great but
putin is not asking for money
putin's not asking for
put insane stay the hell out of my way
that's my country it's my land it
belongs to the motherland
so i i want to say yes
i want i i lean tyler more towards
i was having a conversation with one of
my guys yesterday
and i said i said listen here's what i
lean towards
out of every conflict i've ever had with
another individual or another company or
a competitor in my life in business and
i've had many of them
90 of them were resolved with a phone
call in a conversation
why though
because 90 of them i sat down and spoke
to another reasonable person where
either we offended them there was a
miscommunication there was a
misunderstanding and we were able to
resolve it
do you think that's what putin is
looking at today
or do you think putin's part of the 10
percent that is not willing to reason
because he wants ukraine
do you think putin's gonna live his life
not fighting to get that country back
i don't know i don't i don't see him as
somebody that
prefers um
you know an amicable relationship to
you having that conversation with them
rather than saying no i gotta go fulfill
my vision i don't know we will never
know because we're not on the man's head
we're not but how long has this guy been
ambitious
how many years has this guy been
climbing the ladder from what
organizations from a young guy that
worked his way all the way up having met
everybody during that time and they saw
this guy as a superstar did he make it
all the way to the top you think he made
it to the top because he wants to live
in a big mansion and have all the women
think he's amazing and have dinner with
celebrities hell to the no this guy's a
true believer
of what russia is he believes russia is
the greatest
country in the world you got to respect
the fact that he loves this country i
mean sometimes i wish americans love
their country as much as that guy loves
his country but uh obviously he's not on
the same team and america has to do
whatever they have
and
pat you're going in and out here we're
uh we're having some stream issues
can i lose you guys
we're back with you now pat let me let
me pick up from there and let's get the
american perspective if we can since you
talked about you wish that a lot of
americans loved
our country as much as putin loves his
so i mean at the very least you can
respect him for loving his country i
don't think there's anything wrong with
that
uh biden basically says that the u.s
troops will not engage in direct
conflict with ukraine quote unquote our
forces
are not and will not be engaged in the
conflict our forces are not going to
europe to fight in ukraine but to defend
our nato allies and reassure those
allies in the east putin then responded
any foreign attempt to interfere with
russian action would lead to
consequences they have never seen so
that's sort of the
the uh the battle of words there but
regarding america so it's good to know
that american troops aren't going to be
on the ground there but i wanted to
focus on what will affect americans
over here in the usa and some of that is
gas prices and i know you've had very
strong feelings on inflation you were
the first to basically call
you know gas prices to potentially reach
ten dollars in in california and i think
we've seen evidence that is reaching as
high as
750 i think at one point so i want to
get your thoughts on on what biden has
said regarding gas prices in america
biden said he was working to limit the
fallout of the new sanctions that would
have on the energy prices because we
talked about nordstrom 2 which we can
weigh in on he said the us was ready to
release barrels from the strategic
petroleum reserve i see he said to the
people in his press conference i know
this is hard and that americans are
already hurting i'll do everything in my
power to limit the pain the american
people are feeling
at the gas pump so with that being said
you've already had very strong feelings
on inflation uh now with the uh russians
attacking ukraine
and basically the potential for this
nordstrom 2 to be basically
reversed what are your thoughts on gas
prices and how this basically affects
americans everyday americans getting to
and from work
look
the the part you have to be optimistic
about is the fact that this is not going
to have a long life span that's the
biggest thing you're hoping this is not
going to have a long life span and this
thing gets done very quickly you know in
iran
uh when iran went through the sanctions
and they went through what they were
going through what elon iran did very
quickly was the following that we have
to remember this when u.s put all the
sanctions on iran
do you guys remember what iran did iran
signed a 25-year contract with china for
400 billion dollars
okay so what does this mean so if
u.s put the sanctions on russia
what if china comes from back and says
i'll help support you
because we don't yet know what china's
doing here and you got to realize a lot
of people think russia is the number one
enemy of us
that's not even close
russia is not the number one enemy in
u.s
russia is not who i'm concerned about
the number one enemy of u.s still is
china
it's not russia it's still china
we saw the economy the size of their gdp
three and a half trillion dollars you
know they're smaller than most countries
out there and china is massive
compared to a russia and they're massive
at the same size of u.s the real
heavyweight matchup is china so all i'm
looking for if there's anything i'm
trying to hear folks is the following
i'm just trying to hear what china is
doing behind closed doors that's all i
want to know i want to know what
pat we lost i want to know if
possible
putin do you
do you think she likes america do you
think she's number one enemy is america
or russia do you think she wakes up in
the morning trying to make putin's life
a living hell or do you think she wakes
up in the morning
trying to make america's life a living
kill whose life is it i i think behind
this whole thing uh the part that i'm
very closely watching is china because
if if china leaves russia to himself
russia is eventually going to crack and
they're going to say listen let's stop
let's not do anything and then on the
opposing argument let's let's give the
counter argument what i just said right
now
so here's a counter argument i'm going
to argue myself here in a minute and i
want to hear what you guys think about
this on the commentary on the bottom
okay i want you to think about the
commentary on the bottom and what i'm
saying adam tyler i want you to think
about what i'm saying here okay
so
if china stays out of this
what does putin do
is
is putin doing this because it's going
to be a short quick let's get everything
and move out
if it was very quick and move out and
i'm going to debate myself
would he move 175 000 people
would he build hospitals on the border
would he go out there and bring you know
everything prepared on in case if it's
going to be a blood is is he going to be
ready for that
or is it something that
he's prepared for this thing to last two
four six eight weeks
and let's let's go look at what happened
with azerbaijan and armenia on a smaller
version go to azerbaijan and armenia
in the example of azerbaijan and army
there we go
smaller
it's on
azerbaijan was russia armenia was
ukraine right what happened eventually
with pashina the prime minister
he eventually gave in
and eventually said yeah this is not
good for my people let's stop it we're
losing too many people he came and
negotiated and azerbaijan kind of looked
like the aggressor and they got what
they wanted
in this situation
with russia and ukraine is the current
prime minister a guy that's going to
accept that
i don't know this guy seems like a very
strong true believer that's not willing
to just hand things over
to russia
and people have to realize
ukraine has a pretty strong military
ukraine has a pretty strong they have
they have weapons they're not
lightweights okay but uh again my
biggest fear here adam tyler is china
behind closed doors what kind of
conference calls are they having
and why is putin seem so confident today
why is putin like oh i can go after
anybody
is is somebody behind closed doors
giving him that confidence
is is that what's happening is somebody
being closer saying don't worry about it
i got your back go i won't say anything
but go
because you ever see somebody that goes
from
making a lot of threats and not doing
anything
to all of a sudden making the threats
delivering and being extremely
aggressive
something changed behind closed doors
the person got richer the person got
better weapons the person got better
backing the person got better back up
the person got better uh knowledge the
person got an insider in your country
that is feeding information to them
we don't know
but it's pure
yeah pat you bring up a great point i'm
not sure if you're uh you're cutting in
and out but we
you bring up a great point about
um
what china is doing behind closed doors
because
the second that we left
afghanistan
i said on one of the podcasts i said
short term this is not a good look but
long term this allow us to at least
turn our focus onto what really matters
which is china no doubt i mean i think
we were in afghanistan way too long we
could have got out of there five ten
years ago and been in a way better
position saved a trillion dollars
and we should have turned our attention
to china whether you like trump or don't
like trump he at least
rattled the cage of china and woke up a
lot of the american public to say hey
what the hell is going on here
in china
so
if there is conversations taking beh
taking place behind closed doors between
china and russia you brought up the
example of
you know getting your ex-girlfriend back
russia trying to get ukraine back and
china getting taiwan back
i'm actually proud or happy to see that
that biden is not getting into a war of
words
or
literal hot war
over ukraine he's come out and he's
expressed we will not be sending troops
to fight in ukraine we're backing up
nato that's fine i think at the end of
the day
you think this is going to be a
short-lived situation short-lived war
whether that's weeks whether that's
months what have you
we cannot afford to take our eye off the
prize our eye off the ball of what is
happening with china and as much as
china is an enemy
we can't
you know not have them work with us on
certain things i.e climate change or
whether it's trade or not they're one of
our largest trading partners if not the
largest so this is a delicate line that
biden needs to balance and ukraine yes
it's a major thing it might be a blip on
the radar but he can't let that affect
our relationship with china you have
thoughts on this tyler well and that's
the big ticket right it's china is in
and i mean this is opening the door for
taiwan right i mean this taiwan is is
next on the table so
at what point does biden actually step
up and say no you cannot expand your
borders like this because this i mean
it's reminiscent of world war ii world
war ii when uh when hitler invaded
poland i mean these dictators and
autocrats they get more and more and
more emboldened when we when we pulled
out of afghanistan like you said adam
the first person to swoop in was china
and to sign a deal and and you know they
now have 87 billion dollars worth of
military equipment which normally
wouldn't be a problem to
afghanistan and the taliban operating it
but what i worry about is it being
reverse engineered by the chinese and by
the russians and by them being able to
build military weapons that can match
ours so at what point does biden have to
step in and stop letting these dictators
and autocrats become more and more
emboldened
look let me read this to you here's an
article from the boston globe okay how
the u.s brought china and russia
together okay two generations ago
president nixon realized that the
intensifying partnership between moscow
and beijing could ultimately threaten
the us to prevent that he launched what
turned out to be a spectacularly
successful effort to disrupt their
partnership now we are doing the
opposite pushing china and russia
together
this month the leaders of the two
eurasian behemoths signed a far-reaching
joint statement that may end up shaping
the 21st century the interstate
relations between russia and china are
superior to political and military
alliance alliances of the cold war era
friendship between the two states has no
limits the implications of this accord
are daunting to contemplate especially
now with russia attacking ukraine even
though the us
remains the world's most powerful
country it's disconcerting to see the
two next most powerful countries joining
together that's what i was talking about
earlier worst of all we brought it on
ourselves bashing china and russia for
years was certain to turn them into
partners at some point it just happened
the world turned russian president
vladimir putin and chinese leader
chinese leader chi ching bing signed the
joint statement at the an elaborate uh
ceremony before the opening of the
winter olympics in beijing this just
happened
that they pledged to promote
redistribution of
redistribution of power
in the world and specifically to support
each other's foreign policy priorities
for russia and and to nato expansion and
for china reunification from taiwan with
taiwan as the new china-russia
partnership was being unveiled putin
called it a relationship that will
probably cannot be compared to anything
in the world and i agree
for americans to ignore it would be
foolish continuing to antagonize the
immense bloke would be even worse if we
cannot accommodate the changing world it
may leave us behind so look whether this
guy who's got an opinion here to say
let's not say anything bad about them
you have to be naive to not stand up to
the enemy either and just kind of look
the other way you cannot do that i don't
think you can seem weak in a position in
a situation like this
but u.s has got to kind of get some
powerful
you know other countries to come with us
to go up against these guys because
these are the two i don't know how to
explain this these are
it's it's it's the ultimate powerhouse
super team being put together except
it's two countries two of the top three
countries in the world are coming
together so
this is a real plan the world has to pay
very close attention to this let's let's
play that game for a second i mean we
just saw the the nba all-star game as an
example it was team
lebron versus team
durant and they had basically a draft
right uh lebron picked giannis first and
then durant picked um
uh embiid so on and so forth so if
you're having a
a worldwide draft of countries
and china and russia align
who else is major that is on their side
because if you look at the list uss
canada the uk france italy basically
everyone in the eu
brazil australia japan
south korea you go down the list bang
bang bang bang bang u s other than china
and russia
would have all the heavyweights on their
team what other heavyweights are on team
china russia who iran who else like if
you're doing this draft who else is on
their side
all the true believers are on each
other's side
you have to realize a lot of the other
guys are more vanilla not saying we're
vanilla
in america look at america right now
americans are at each other's throat
america in the last couple of years
during covet while during 9 11 we united
during covet we were divided
because rather than making china the
enemy
you know democrats may trump the enemy
and that divided america
that made democrats hate republicans
republicans say democrats not everybody
but it became that antagonistic dinners
were being canceled because family
members couldn't have a basic civil
conversation together but why because we
were at each other's throat
when's the last time you heard about uh
media and china that they're at each
other's throat
how about in iran how about in russia
those three countries
no
they don't allow media in china or
or in iran
you're not but you're talking about
three countries
that hate
america
they hate america and they keep
recruiting other countries that also
hate america
so
this this next phase
this next phase
the concern i have with the system that
we have in america is each president
comes with a different agenda and it
changes every four to eight years so we
can't really create a lot of momentum
there's a lot of division there's it's
hard to create momentum to create a
unified enemy while the other guys keep
their enemies unified so
anyways look i'm always optimistic about
what the future looks like because i
think the american people have overcome
a lot of different challenges all i'm
saying is the next 15 moves
america makes
has to be very
we have to be united on this issue
it would be great to see trump and biden
right now
in this issue coming together
it would be great to see a lot of our
leaders in u.s coming together saying
hey
look we don't agree on taxes we don't
agree on xyz we don't agree we don't
even like each other but we love america
more than we love our ego and we won't
let you know america is more important
to us in china russia ukraine anybody
else
this is our land first we love this
country this is the greatest country in
the world
america needs something like that to
scare the crap out of everybody else out
there but america right now keeps
getting weaker and weaker and weaker
because we don't look united pbd you
brought up the fact that trump had some
favorable words to say about putin i
believe that was two days ago this was
prior to the to the attack
uh i would hope that maybe his tune has
changed since the attack
you brought up the fact that maybe biden
and trump to a joint press conference or
i know you've been obviously working on
getting
obama and trump to do some sort of
sit-down together
obviously you know you're thinking
positive of what would be best for
america if you can put yourself into
trump shoes right now what do you think
trump
should do to help unify america over
this situation in russia because
obviously he has not said anything bad
about putin publicly possibly ever is
this a time for him to speak out what
would you do if uh if you were trump
right about now
well you have to realize he doesn't
believe in the current head coach
he doesn't believe in the current
commander-in-chief he has zero respect
for the guy but he believes in america
i i
i'm not you heard what i just said i
think they need to do i just gave you my
proposal what they need to do
it would be great for america to show
strength of us doing that
but we're not there right now i mean i i
i already talked about what trump would
do if it was him but trump may also look
at this opportunity to say many of the
american people may sit there and say
look
i i didn't like you trump and i still
don't like you but i prefer you as a
president over biden if you think how
trump thinks
trump still walks around in mar-a-lago
and everywhere he goes as if he's the
current president
i i i you have to think how he thinks
he still thinks he's the president he's
he keeps saying your president what does
that mean his emails end with your
president your president
he
in his mind there's a 90 chance he's
gonna be the president two years three
years and he's gonna see he's gonna let
this thing to get so ugly in america for
him to come and say you miss me yet and
then that's how his legacy is gonna end
in his early 80s and then he's going to
go and do whatever he wants to do for
the rest of his life
and history will say they impeached him
twice but he came back and he saved
america from world war cold war about
that's kind of how he sees themselves so
he doesn't see himself as a person
that's going to call biden and say let
me give you some feedback he doesn't
seem so do you think he should call out
putin at this point
look okay so go back to brexit do you
remember brexit of course you guys
remember brexit
a lot of people weren't for brexit
do you remember how big of a topic it
was
but trump was okay with brexit
he was kind of okay with it do you guys
remember what position he had for it he
was okay with brexit
a lot of people and you weren't okay for
brexit
a lot of different people weren't okay
for brexit what do you mean we let them
out
and and he would say well all these
other countries that are in there
they're not paying their fair share
why are they in it
why they're not paying their fair share
so there was an element of admiration he
had for putin
to not rely on nato and stand on his own
because it's kind of like i don't need
you i can do it on my own because that's
kind of what he did i don't need my dad
i can stand on my own i can go out there
and make it in manhattan and i'm going
to make him my dad made it in jersey but
i'm going to make it in manhattan so he
admires people like that
who don't want to get into the help of
all these other people and you know he
admires that he admires men like that he
doesn't see putin as
you know a country that he's sitting
there saying at least i don't think
uh he trump is america first one million
percent but he probably looks at putin
as a strategist saying he's exploiting
biden right now after seeing how taliban
exploited biden with afghanistan and how
china is trying to exploit biden with
taiwan putin's trying to exploit biden
with ukraine if he can get it why not
putin is probably sitting there saying
wait a minute the taliban got
afghanistan why can't i get ukraine this
is my time you don't think those types
of conversations took place i think a
big part of how
biden handled afghanistan is what led to
putin attacking and wanting to get
ukraine back i may be wrong but that's
what i believe well he's been on their
border since i mean crimea happened in
2014 so that's what's going on
maybe that was more of an impetus to say
all right now's the time after looking
what's happened in afghanistan
but you know it it's sort of
contradictory it's it's like okay i i'm
america first but you know and and i
want
and then he but he's also called out
nato and he hasn't spoken out against
putin but he respects putin but he also
wants to use this situation
to basically look better in the to the
american people but then again as you
said biden actually looked good if we
looked at the stock market right now the
stock market is performing well so
people are actually you know maybe hey
biden's doing a pretty good job he's put
on the sanctions so i think there's no
clear-cut answers especially when you
throw trump in the mix
what the hell to make of this situation
so i know that we're kind of
wrapping up the podcast soon but
basically
what are your key takeaways from
everything that's going on and what
should the average american or the
average person worldwide really
be on the lookout for and pay attention
to
look if this is going to be a complete
left field the type of feedback i'll
give to you guys so i'm watching a guy
who's doing an interview from ukraine
and he says we were not expecting this
there was a longest line today in gas
station where people are leaving they
didn't have weapons they didn't have
this they didn't have that to the
average person i would say proper
preparation prevents poor performance
look
when i got when i got married
my wife i got a range rover and i parked
it outside
one day we come i go to sleep i wake up
in the morning the entire window was
shattered
stereo system was stolen everything the
next day i bought a shotgun and i bought
a gun okay i bought a shotgun and a gun
because i had a kid chico was born and i
said it's my job to by the way i'm
living in california doing that and i'm
a military background so i kind of know
how to use this stuff because i used it
for the years that i was in the military
so if you have a wife and a kid and a
husband and family and people to protect
it's kind of your duty to protect them
what do you do with that proper
preparation prevents poor performance
you got to secure your family right
number two
these guys didn't go to the gas station
if you're kind of seeing crisis is
taking place you got to look at yourself
what is crisis today i've been saying
for the longest time
cash is king for the individual not for
the billionaire not for the millionaire
not for all those other guys
but cash is king where you got to have
an emergency fund ready in case
something does take place okay now on
top of that if you go and look at
buffett do you remember how everybody
was talking about why does buffett have
200 billion dollars in cash what does he
know that we don't know what does he
know that we don't know
maybe he was expecting something like
this to happen
maybe he was expecting a correction or a
world or something to happen where the
economy may take a hit but the economy
hasn't taken a hit yet but the biggest
thing for the average person is stay
alert stay alive educate yourself
listen to commentary on both sides
try not to listen to the commentary of
just one side because then you're going
to be fooled first thing i did when i'm
watching everything i'm reading articles
from people who hate trump i'm reading
articles from people who hate biden if
you only read articles from people that
hate biden you're gonna have a blind
spot and if you only read articles from
people that hate trump you're also gonna
have a blind spot do not be naive today
okay do not mean these guys didn't wake
up this morning wanted to put food on
your table they woke up this morning
wanted to make sure they look good in
front of camera and the legacy show's
good about them being a president you
and i have to go do that we have to go
take care of our families and look again
another reminder proper preparation
prevents poor performance and stay alert
stay alive educate yourself um but
having said that my computer here is
about to die i really enjoyed uh uh
jumping on and having this dialogue with
you guys for the people in ukraine man
our our prayers are with you
uh i i i know war it sucks i remember as
a kid till today's got an effect on me i
watch certain movies and i immediately
go back to iran some of these effects
are going to have effects on these kids
that's going to last decades
but uh you know
god willing there's going to be some
kind of a decision being made here
quickly for this to end because war
never benefits the world politically
sometimes it does it benefits some
companies but it doesn't benefit the
people and that's what my biggest
concern is today a lot of regular people
that are innocent they haven't done
anything wrong they're being affected by
this
hopefully this sense very quickly well
thank you pbd i know you said your
computer's dying slow uh pretty soon
thank you tyler for jumping on thank you
for everybody who's been tuning in i
think we got 11 000 watching live right
now so thank you for jumping on with us
this was an emergency uh podcast i would
say i would say adam if people are here
for the first time subscribe to the
channel because we may do another update
tomorrow or the next day if anything
else changes we may do another emergency
podcast in the next couple days uh so
just keep that part of mind for folks
that just got on for the first time okay
pat so um again to reiterate what pat
just said if this is your first time on
the channel welcome to the ppd podcast
welcome to valuetainment please
subscribe uh this is what we do please
subscribe and hit the bell too subscribe
hit the bell pat if you would give us
your final words and take us out
future looks bright guys you know we've
overcome a lot of massive crisis a lot
of things have happened in the past
before and anytime you're in it just
think about the day kobet hit and how
worried all of us were when you were
worried whether you're a non-essential
or an essential and i remember we were
non-essential and i would still come to
work every day i went 90 days to work
without missing i only miss one sunday
away from the office
during that time i spent a lot of time
my kids i would go to the office with my
kids and all the people around me that
were worried it's the end of the world
what if this is like that movie
contagion and contagion the movie went
viral and all these movies that were
about viral
things when you know people are watching
and getting more and more and more
scared the reality of it is things are
never as scary as your imagination makes
it out to be and it's never as great as
your imagination imagination makes it
out to be it helps to be in the middle
it helps to stay optimistic it helps to
stay a little paranoid it helps to be
aware it helps to not to not to be naive
but at the end of the day mankind has
overcome a lot of difficult situations
and this won't be the last time we do it
as uh as they as they say only the
paranoid survive so uh pat thanks for
the call in uh enjoy your time in mexico
and we'll see you when you get back take
care everybody bye bye bye
bye
you